könnte es sein dass die mobilität der
zukunft die viel gepriesene
elektromobilität mit all ihren
versprechen bezüglich der rettung des
weltklimas von ein paar wenigen nicht
gerade freiheitlich demokratisch
regierten ländern abhängt von ländern
wie zum beispiel der demokratischen
republik kongo ja du hast richtig gehört
und nein ich habe nicht den verstand
verloren also merkt ihr diesen namen
demokratische republik kongo acht und
übrigens ist die schon mal aufgefallen
dass gerade nicht besonders
demokratische also vom volk regierte
staaten sehr gerne solchen wie
demokratisch oder volk ihren namen
tragen aber das nur so am rande zurück
zu unseren schönen schicken elektroautos
mit denen wir den planeten retten wollen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin überzeugt davon dass viele jedes
mal wenn sie von einem tesla oder einem
vw allerdings hören an eine saubere
umwelt grüne bäume rauschende wälder
nachhaltige verkehrsmittel gesunde luft
und glückliche tiere denken irgendwann
hat uns das ganze elektroauto marketing
all diese bilder in unsere gehirne
gepflanzt so dass wir gar nicht anders
können als uns nun als wahres
superhelden zu fühlen wenn sie
elektrisch mit 250 über die autobahn
brettern die umwelt mann der den
planeten vor der zerstörung durch die
schmutzigen verbrennungsmotoren rettet
aber was wäre wenn dieses durch die
volks erziehungs medien gesamtbild nicht
der realität entsprechen würde bevor er
fortfahren möchte ich eine kleine
klarstellung vornehmen in diesem video
wollen wir weder das elektroauto
schlechtmachen noch seine technologie
kritisieren oder ähnliches sondern das
ganze aus der oft unterschätzten ja für
den meisten geradezu ignorierten
geopolitischen perspektive betrachten ja
es mag berechtigte zweifel daran geben
ob die technologie ausgereift genug ist
oder ob die zukunft wirklich dem
elektroauto gehören wird aber ist
unbestreitbar dass viele seiner vorteile
es faszinierend sind und es in
bestimmten durchaus wichtigen
einsatzbereichen zum beispiel auf
kurzstrecken im stadtverkehr viele
pluspunkte bietet
[Musik]
all das ist wahr zur wahrheit gehört
vielleicht aber auch das marketing und
politiker dafür gesorgt haben dass wir
jedes mal wenn das elektroauto auf kommt
nur seine positiven seiten hervorheben
isaac selektiver wahrnehmung hat ein
mythisches weltbild um diese technologie
herum geschaffen die allgegenwärtige
verklärung hat eine erhebliche
aufklärungslücke geschaffen und genau
aus diesem grund glauben wir dass wir
diese dringend schließen müssen indem
wir mehr über die auswirkungen dieses
technologischen wandels sprechen
ökologische soziale und vor allem
geopolitische auswirkungen und genau
deshalb haben wir dieses video
vorbereitet sie die zum beispiel diese
grafik an
[Musik]
was du in dieser grafik siehst ist
nichts geringeres als die gewaltige
menge an mineralien die für die
herstellung eines elektrofahrzeugs und
eines konventionellen fahrzeugs benötigt
wird wenn wir den verbrauch von stahl
und aluminium ausklammern wie du siehst
werden für die herstellung eines
elektroautos viel mehr rohstoffe
benötigt ungefähr sechsmal mehr und es
ist nicht nur jede menge es geht auch um
deren art vielfalt und seltenheit und
die auswirkungen welche ihre gewinnung
und verarbeitung mit sich bringt
[Musik]
während für die herstellung eines
konventionellen autos nur geringe mengen
an kupfer und mangan benötigt werden
benötigen elektroautos auch eine
beträchtliche menge an lithium nickel
kobalt grafit und eine auswahl an
seltenen erden das macht die produktion
nicht nur teurer sondern erfordert auch
viel komplexere lieferketten so müssen
zum beispiel nicht nur viel mehr
mineralien abgebaut sondern auch mehr
mineralien von ihrem förderer ort zu den
orten transportiert werden an dem sie
verarbeitet und schließlich verwendet
werden und natürlich sind die mittel zur
förderung und transport nicht gerade
sauber von maschinen bis hin zu schiffen
wir reden hier von aktivitäten bei denen
sehr viel erdöl verbrannt wird und zwar
nicht in emissionsarmen euro 6 oder euro
sieben dieselmotoren sondern in den
dreckigsten schwer übel motoren die ihr
euch vorstellen könnt
[Musik]
denn auf den weltmeeren gibt es nun mal
keine asu plaketten von den ganzen
leckagen und öl abfälle dieser in den
ozean landen mal ganz zu schweigen und
nimm dich in acht denn das ist erst der
anfang also möchtest du auch mal die
weniger attraktive seite der e-mobilität
kennenlernen jene dunkle seite über die
uns die aktivisten und politiker sich zu
sagen wollen bist du genau wissen wie
der kolossale wandel des bergbaus
aussieht der im gange ist eine
transformation der rohstoffwirtschaft
und lieferketten die ihresgleichen sucht
eventuell vergleichbar mit der
umstellung auf kriegswirtschaft und was
vielleicht noch wichtiger ist willst du
wissen wer die hauptakteure und
hauptprofiteure dieser ganzen bergbau
revolution sind die gerade stattfindet
dann bleibt dran heute werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten aber zuerst
müssen wir selbst noch etwas von diesem
thema und von deine aufmerksamkeit
profitieren in unserem letzten video
haben wir ja schon davon erzählt wie
wichtig das thema sicherheit im internet
noch werden da das risiko oli zahl von
angriffen explosionsartig ansteigt und
die wahrheit ist jeder von uns wird
einfach mehr für seine eigenes cyber
sicherheit tun müssen um nicht
ausgeliefert zu sein dazu werden viele
verschiedene dinge die
verhaltensänderungen und mehr technische
bildung gehören aber auch ein gewisses
standardmaßen ausstattung und ein sehr
wichtiger baustein der persönlichen
sicherheit im netz stellt dabei
zweifellos ein vpn dann wenn du noch gar
nicht benutzt solltest du dich ganz
sicher damit auseinandersetzen denn ein
wirklich sicheres vpn dass weder
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lockt erhöht ganz
einfach deinen persönlichen grad an
anonymität und senkt damit das risiko
durch hacker bzw automatisierte anderes
mechanismen identifiziert zu werden und
deswegen müssen wir unbedingt den vpn
service unseres tollen sponsor server
ibm ans herz legen search art bietet
unzählige sicherheitsfeatures zum
beispiel web dass alle cookies tops und
auch fortgeschrittene elektrifizierung
des verfolgungs methoden von denen man
oft gar nicht sicher bloggt und die
damit verbundenen gefahren beseitigt
natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe
auch auf websites und internet dienste
zugreifen die in dem land in dem er
gerade seid nicht verfügbar sind ohne
zensur und geblockt daheim oder im
urlaub ihr könnt auch netflix und andere
streaming dienste die ihre inhalte nur
in den usa anbieten von europa ausnutzen
aber nicht nur das wenn du eine soft
control könnt ihr alle eure geräte in
vpn registrieren handys notebooks und
sogar ein smart tvs steckt wirklich alle
arten von geräten ab ihr bekommt damit
einen lückenlosen schutz so und wenn ihr
den schadcode politik.de angeht bekommt
ihr von servtag auch noch ein rabatt von
30 prozent und um weil die ersten drei
monate gratis dazu links zu diesen
angebot findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video also nichts wie los
besorgt euch so stark und geist damit
leise wir uns finanziell unter die arme
das könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt mit
hilfe des paypal ständen links den ich
aus ebenfalls in die beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hätte
uns auch in zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere videos zu liefern so und nun das
uns schnell wieder zum thema dieses
videos zurückkommen und zur beantwortung
der frage wer sind die hauptakteure und
hauptprofiteure der e mobilitäts bergbau
revolution
der hässlichste aspekt der
elektromobilität
wie ihr euch vorhin erklärt haben
braucht man verglichen mit der
herstellung eines herkömmlichen autos
für die herstellung eines
elektrofahrzeugs nicht nur die
sechsfache menge an mineralien sondern
auch ein um den faktor drei breiteres
spektrum dieser wertvollen nicht
erneuerbaren und oft nur schwer
recyclebaren materialien die frage
lautet also welche konsequenzen hat das
alles fangen wir mal mit folgender
grafik an
[Musik]
die länder die du in dieser grafik sind
jene länder die im prinzip am meisten
vom e mobilitäts bergbau profitieren
werden dabei lohnt es sich diejenigen
hervorzuheben welche über jenes die
mineralien verfügung die wir als
wesentlich einstufen können kupfer
graphit nickel und natürlich lithium
finden wir unter den großen akteuren
länder wie chile china australien
indonesien aber auch weniger bekannte
länder wie die demokratische republik
kongo ein land das heute praktisch ein
monopol auf dem weltmarkt für kobold hat
das sind diese pommes oder internet
tolle oder so ihr wisst schon
nehmen wir mal ich hab da was
verwechselt er genau das kann nicht
stimmen
jetzt hab ich's kobalt ja jetzt fällt
mir wieder ein kowal ein chemisches
element mit dem m s symbol coo unter
ordnungszahl 27 das weiß doch jeder wir
haben doch alle schon in der schule
gelernt das kobalt ein magnetisches
übergangs metall ist das leichteste
element aus der neuen gruppe des
periodensystems welche deswegen eben
auch kobalt gruppe genannt wird und
nicht gold gruppe mann oh mann da hätte
ich mich ja beinahe ganz schön blamiert
und das obwohl ich ja eigentlich aus der
chemie komme ja noch so ein schnitzer
und ich könnte kanzlerkandidat oder
außenminister werden natürlich nicht in
einer bananenrepublik wie der
demokratischen republik kongo da muss
man denke ich schon mehr auf dem kasten
haben denn glaubt mir dort politiker zu
sein wird sich in den nächsten jahren
mächtig lohnen einen besseren weg
schnell reich zu werden findet ihn
momentan sehr schwer denn nicht weniger
als 60 prozent des weltweit verwendeten
kobalt stammt aus genau diesen
afrikanischen land südlich der sahara
[Musik]
verstehst du jetzt warum wir am anfang
des videos gesagt haben dass die
elektromobilität sondern der
demokratischen republik kongo und der
dortigen korrupten politiker kaste
abhängt wir reden von einem land mit
einer wirklich schrecklichen geschichte
und einer zukunft welche noch mehr geld
in die kassen jenes kleinen grüppchen
von wichtigen spielen wird die das 92
millionen volk brutal unterdrückt
tatsache ist eben dass es alles andere
als einfach ist alle für elektroautos
benötigten mineralien zu beschaffen vor
allem wenn es um stückzahlen geht welche
den mobilitätsbedarf kompletter
industrieländer decken soll aber lasst
uns diese problematik doch noch mal
genauer unter die lupe nehmen damit wir
nicht nur irgendwas behaupten sondern
anhand von zahlen beweisen können von
welchem ausmaß hier die rede ist unser
beispiel des kobolds aus dem coro eignet
sich dazu hervorragend
dieses mineral ist wenn der größten wenn
nicht sogar die größte einnahmequelle
des zentralafrikanischen landes in der
demokratischen republik kongo werden
jedes jahr mehr als
95.000 tonnen kobalt gefördert eine
menge die bis 2020 stetig anstieg bis
der durch die massen hygiene shutdowns
zur eindämmung des virus verursachte
stillstand der weltwirtschaft dieses
wachstum bremst
tatsache ist dass in der drk jährlich
95.000 tonnen kobalt aus dem boden
geholt werden so und jetzt haltet euch
fest ein fünftel davon also fast 20.000
tonnen jährlich werden per hand aus
rudimentären also behelfsmäßigen medien
geholt die jeder beschreibung spotten
dieses kobalt wird dann hauptsächlich
über das staatliche unternehmen etc
weiter verkauft wie du dir vorstellen
kannst herrschen in diesen minen welche
aufgrund der in kongo allgegenwärtigen
kobalt bonanza wie pilze aus dem boden
schießen katastrophal erbärmlichen
bedingungen in bezug auf
arbeitssicherheit umweltschutz und löhne
nun ja diese sind derart tragisch dass
du sie dir eigentlich gar nicht
vorstellen kannst auch wenn du ganz fest
die augen schließt während dich dein
tesla autopilot mit 150 sachen über die
autobahn regiert tatsächlich verdienen
die bergleute das kobalt abbauen welches
für die herstellung von elektroautos
unerlässlich ist weniger als drei dollar
am tag und wir sprechen hier von
marathon arbeitstagen die von
frühmorgens bis spätabends dauern denn
wo viel geld zu machen ist und es kaum
rechtliche rahmenbedingungen gibt die
früher kapitalistische zustände
einnehmen würden entstehen natürlich
sehr schnell extrem ausbeuterische
geschäftsmodelle wir sprechen hier über
perfekt ausgearbeitet und konzertierte
fast clarus konzepte mit denen eine
große zahl von in elend leben der
menschen angelockt und dann in
abhängigkeit gebracht werden kann wenn
diese sich dann für die rettung des
planeten und natürlich der profite der
gesamten industrie zu tode schuften
schwerste kinderarbeit ist dabei eher
die norm als die ausnahme
natürlich hat der gewaltige anstieg der
nachfrage im rahmen des forcierten
umstieg auf das elektroauto der durch
staatliche vorschriften erzwungen wird
dazu geführt dass diese art von minen
die sich in den meisten fällen wie der
nähe von ballungszentren befinden und
direkt an wohnviertel an grenzen in den
hintergrund treten und industrielle
großen an bedeutung gewinnen trotzdem
existieren sie und die zahl der von
ihnen betroffenen menschen nimmt stetig
zu
[Applaus]
aber das ist nicht das einzige problem
auch unter umweltgesichtspunkten und das
ist ja der kern ganzen elektroauto frage
ist die bilanz dieser minen
beziehungsweise der gesamten branche
katastrophal zahlreichen aktuellen
berichten zufolge gibt es in goldminen
so gut keine maßnahmen um die
umweltauswirkungen des abbaus zu mindern
zum beispiel werden die riesigen tagebau
nicht saniert wenn die vorkommen darin
mal ausgebeutet sind während des abbaus
gibt es keinerlei abfallentsorgung und
vielerorts wurde sogar ein erheblicher
anstieg der radioaktivität festgestellt
der die krebsraten der bevölkerung
explodieren lässt von das ist noch nicht
alles
[Musik]
außerdem wird das mineral oft in
natürliche gewässer gespült die dann
kontaminiert sind in vielen fällen
befinden sich diese wasserquellen in
direkter nähe zu wohngebieten so dass
das verseuchte und radioaktive wasser in
den nahrungskreislauf gelangt und direkt
oder indirekt für den menschlichen
verzehr genutzt wird vergessen wir nicht
dass wir über das afrika südlich der
sahara sprechen und dass die
wasserwirtschaft dort ein bisschen
kompliziert ist um es milde auszudrücken
[Musik]
dann gibt es noch das problem der
unkontrollierten staub emissionen
emissionen die in trockenen jahreszeiten
gewaltige wolken mit kobalt
mikropartikeln erzeugen die übers land
ziehen diese sind für menschen
hochgradig giftig und verursachen
atemwegs erkrankungen und krebs und
vergesst nicht dass wir hier nicht über
einzelfälle sprechen allein in den
manuellen mienen der demokratischen
republik kongo arbeiten schätzungsweise
zwischen 150.000 und 200.000 menschen
und das sind nur jene welche wirklich
physisch direkt in den minen valoren
denn mehr als eine weitere million sind
indirekt von dieser wirtschaftsaktivität
abhängig und kommen meist auch mit dem
kobalt in kontakt natürlich ist das
alles nicht die schuld des elektroautos
an sich aber der zunehmende staatliche
regulatorische druck zugunsten des
elektromotors alle akteure dazu gebracht
lieber wegzuschauen und lieber die
exorbitanten profite mitzunehmen ja ich
habe sogar gehört dass man der reichste
mensch der welt werden kann wenn man vor
der hässlichen seite dieser bewegung
einfach nur fest genug die augen
zudrückt und schön kohle abstaubt aber
natürlich ist nicht alles was wir über
diese bergbau revolution sagen können
schlecht ganz und gar nicht wir können
auch viele positive dinge entdecken zum
beispiel wirtschaftliche auswirkungen
viele der länder die diese wichtigen
mineralien fördern werden riesige
geldbeträge einnehmen in denen sie
versuchen können der armut ein für
allemal zu entkommen das heißt rein
theoretisch wenn keine gruppen politiker
und profit geil konzernmanager beteiligt
werden nun das sind sie aber genauer
gesagt sind sie nicht nur irgendwie
beteiligt sie sind die hauptakteure
welche diese trends maßgeblich pushen
politiker wie der ehemalige präsident
von bgc dem kongolesischen stars
unternehmen das einen großen teil der
kobalt produktion kontrolliert nun wurde
der gute mann 2000 ansonsten lassen
nachdem er etwas zu tief in die kasse
gegriffen hatte ganze 8,8 milliarden
dollar aus dem cooper als geschäfts-
oder abgezweigt und auf eigene konten
gelenkt haben geld das im grunde
genommen nun irgendwie verschwunden ist
dritter dezember 2021 kongo entlässt
führenden bergbau manager in einer wolke
von korruptionsvorwürfen
der vorsitzende der staatlichen
bergbaugesellschaft demokratischen
republik kongo wurde am freitag
abgesetzt nachdem lange zeit behauptet
wurde dass milliarden von dollar an
einnahmen verschwunden sind also wie ihr
seht gibt es zum glück nicht nur
schlechte nachrichten der investition in
den bergbau haben die situation vieler
familien verbessert sie haben jetzt
einen job und eine stabile
einkommensquelle
[Applaus]
die familie des ehemaligen etc chef zum
beispiel muss sicher nicht mehr am
hungertuch nagen tja wie hieß es doch so
schön im real existierenden kommunismus
wer nicht cloud beklaut seine familie
und wie ihr seht gilt dies im heutigen
staatlich geförderten öko
raubtierkapitalismus noch immer aber an
dieser stelle fragen sich viele von euch
vielleicht lieber mark was meinst du mit
staatlich geförderten öko
raubtierkapitalismus die von ihr
vorgetragenen missstände spielen sich
doch in entwicklungsländern ab willst du
uns etwa erzählen dass wenn wir die
herstellung eines elektroautos muss
diese verschiedenen radien benötigt
werden und diese mineralien ausgerechnet
in armen ländern zu finden sind diese
ganze entwicklung von entwickelteren
ländern aus und von deren großkonzernen
gesteuert wird vom mächtigen akteuren in
reichen ländern welche diesen gesamten
prozess eigentlich kontrollieren ja
genau das will ich damit sagen jeder tat
kontrolliert vor allem ein land einen
großteil der produktion und verarbeitung
von wichtigen mineralien für die
energiewende hast du eine idee welches
design könnte nein gut dann schauen wir
uns die ganze chose mal an
[Musik]
der krieg um die bergbau revolution
liebe freunde von visual politik ich
habe euch gerade eine frage gestellt auf
die viele sicher schon eine klare
antwort haben manche aber wahrscheinlich
noch zögern welches land kontrolliert
heute den abbau und die verarbeitung der
sogenannten rohstoffe der zukunft die
vereinigten staaten die niederlande
vielleicht die schweiz juni auch in
diesem fall lautet die antwort und es
tut mir unendlich leid es war echt nicht
unsere absicht aber wir haben keine
andere wahl als wieder einmal über china
ja die sogenannte volksrepublik china zu
sprechen
mit 1,4 milliarden einwohnern der
zweitgrößten armee der welt der größten
industrieproduktion und einer regierung
die in letzter zeit die zügel immer
fester an sieht wie könnten wir da nicht
über china sprechen wir müssen uns daran
gewöhnen denn ob es dir gefällt oder
nicht die chinesen werden immer häufiger
die hauptakteure der internationalen
wirtschaft und politik sein und dieser
fall ist keine ausnahme sind wie zb die
folgende grafik an
[Musik]
wie du siehst kontrolliert china die
verarbeitung fast aller wichtigen
mineralien für die energiewende von
elektroautos über makro batterien bis
hin zu solarzellen mit anderen worten
man könnte fast sagen dass china die
energiewende kontrolliert obwohl es vor
allem die westlichen regierungen sind
die sie durchziehen wollen während die
usa in saubere energie investieren gibt
es ein großes problem
china kontrolliert die lieferkette und
nun stellt sich die frage wie um alles
in der welt ist es eigentlich dazu
gekommen wie um alles in der welt kann
china die verarbeitung von mineralien
kontrollieren die es selbst nicht
produziert nun die antwort scheint
einfach sie waren schneller oder haben
es zumindest ernster genommen nehmen wir
an die chinesische regierung hatte eine
klare vorstellung das ist angesichts der
richtung in welche die westlichen
regierungen die wirtschaft drücken sehr
lohnenswert sein könnte sowohl die
produktion als auch die verarbeitung
dieser mineralien zu kontrollieren
gesagt getan
chinesische unternehmen stürzten sich
darauf bergbauunternehmen zu kaufen als
gäbe es kein morgen wie du siehst geht
es hier um so etwas wie den heiligen
gral der weltwirtschaft in den
jahrzehnten die jetzt auf uns zukommen
die begehrtesten gefragtesten und
wichtigsten ressourcen wird noch einen
blick auf diese grafik
was du hier siehst ist nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als die erwartete
entwicklung der nachfrage nach jeder
einzelnen dieser ressourcen und du
siehst dass die nachfrage nach lithium
bis 2040 um das 42 fache nach graphit um
das 25-fache nach cobalt und das
21-fache nach nickel um das 19-fache und
nach seltenen erden um das siebenfache
steigen wird und man muss keine
renommierter politik oder finanzanalyst
sein um zu erkennen was das bedeuten
könnte durch eine einseitige ausrichtung
der energie und verkehrspolitik auf
elektrofahrzeuge wird die strategische
abhängigkeit vieler westlicher länder
von china nie dagewesene höhen schnellen
in sphären der abhängigkeit die wir uns
heute noch gar nicht vorstellen können
die frage ist daher bedeutet dies dass
china die oberhand behalten wird oder
wer ganz schnell die wende von der
energiewende einleiten müssen um nicht
in 20 jahren ganz nach pekings pfeife
tanzen zu müssen nun ja und nein oder
zumindest nicht ganz nicht beides
gleichzeitig dass mich das erklären
[Musik]
einerseits kontrolliert die meisten
dieser mineralien so dass sein einfluss
enorm sein könnte andererseits dürfen
wir nicht vergessen dass die
technologische entwicklung die
erforschung und die suche nach
praktikablen alternativen dazu beitragen
können diese abhängigkeit zu mildern
aber natürlich nicht zu beseitigen wir
haben zum beispiel den fall der
wasserstoff brennstoffzellen fahrzeuge
eine technologie über die wir hier auf
visuelle politik preis gesprochen haben
ich werde das entsprechende video und
der beschreibung für euch verlinken
wasserstoff brennstoffzellen autos sind
im gegensatz zum herkömmlichen batterie
elektroauto von all diesen radien in
viel geringerem ausmaß abhängig bei
ihrer herstellung werden zum beispiel
kaum kupfer kobalt nickel oder lithium
verwendet etwas schlechter schneiden sie
nur bei seltenen erden aluminium und vor
allem platin ab dieses material ist
derzeit sehr knapp aber es gibt viel
spielraum für die erkundung neuer
vorkommen die frage ist daher wo wird
platin produziert und befindet es sich
auch in chinesischer hand
[Musik]
nun ja zwei drittel des weltweit
produzierten platins stammen aus
südafrika und ein gutes stück dahinter
kommt russland und hier kommt die gute
nachricht für alle die sich sorgen um
eine zu große abhängigkeit von china
machen kein einziges der fünf größten
platin produzierenden unternehmen der
welt wird von dem asiatischen riesen
kontrolliert nicht ein einziges hier ist
es sogar umgekehrt china ist von anderen
abhängig und solange shipping dieses
video nicht zu sehen bekommt sieht es
nicht danach aus als ob sich die dinge
ändern heute wird platin von
amerikanischen britischen
südafrikanischen und russischen
unternehmen kontrolliert wie du siehst
ist es alles andere als unbedeutend in
welche richtung die energie und
verkehrswende gesteuert wird wie immer
ist es extrem wichtig genau zu
differenzieren und alle entscheidungen
in ihren konsequenzen zu ende zu denken
zu lange hat uns die politik mit
apokalyptischen angst rhetorik auf der
einen seite und inkompetenten heiß
versprechen auf der anderen den verstand
vernebelt ohne auf die details zu achten
dies gilt übrigens nicht nur für den
klimawandel und die energiewende es ist
zu einem handlungsmuster geworden und
die meisten leute vor allem darauf
leider immer noch herein
[Musik]
denn wie so oft werden auch die besten
vorsätze dieser unausgewogenen
einseitigen und monokausal energiewende
zu keinem anderen ziel führen als in die
hölle nun ist ein schnelles umsteuern
eine rasche kurskorrektur dringend
geboten der jetzige kurs bei dem alle
politik wirtschaft medien und
gesellschaft einzig und allein auf die
elektroauto technologie setzen wird uns
nirgendwo sonst hinführen als in die
hölle der geopolitischen und geo
ökonomischen abhängigkeit von der pseudo
kommunistischen partei chinas weder
tesla noch roll oder volkswagen werden
die hauptakteure beim übergang zum
elektroauto sein denn vor ihnen steht
peking das ist das ziel von shipping und
wir stellen mit vollgas beziehungsweise
mit voll spannung darauf zu aber jetzt
bist du an der reihe glaubst du wirklich
dass es gefährlich sein können dass
china die wichtigsten in der realen für
die energiewende kontrolliert denkst du
dass westliche regierungen etwas dagegen
unternehmen sollten wäre es eine gute
idee auch alternativen so fördern mit
dem wasserstoffauto anstatt bis
herkömmlichen elektroautos
weiterzumachen wie immer sind wir auf
deine meinung zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass dieses
video gefallen hat falls ja gibt uns
mitteilen like empfehle ist ein freundin
vergisst nicht das abo mit glöckchen und
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
und unterstützung unserer arbeit bitte
auch mit einer kleinen spende über den
link in der beschreibung unter diesem
video machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]